hey
movie retrospective let's see what did
the patreon
patrons choose on the poll this week
stephen king adaptation from 1984
children of the corn yeah not a bad
flick i remember it
outlander remember it we saw it again
and i was just like yeah okay i remember
this [ __ ]
was the interesting thing about this
movie is that i think i probably saw
this let's say [ __ ] it came out in 1984
uh when i was 12 years old i don't think
i saw in the theater but i saw it on
cable like as soon as it came out on
cable
so i saw it when i was like a preteen or
like an early teenager
and i remember really digging it i saw
it probably like hundreds of times
because i think i've taped it off cable
or whatever
and watched it a bunch of times but then
i didn't watch it again
for many years and then just recently
watched it again
and it's still okay but
it doesn't i think it doesn't hold up as
well as an adult
i think it's more like it works out
better if you're a kid because i think
you can relate to the kid characters
better
well also it was a movie of its time
well done so back
in those days it was it was a lot more
exciting
it's not a bad movie it's yeah it's not
even like one of the worst i mean
stephen king kind of has a reputation
for some of his like adaptations being
bad but it's like this
this would be like mid-tier yeah i think
upper mid
yeah upper mid actually you know it's
not as good as christine or the dead
zone but you know
it's not as bad as maximum overdrive
some of that other footage or
sleepwalkers
yeah or the langley
[Laughter]
it's um kind of akin to watching a good
dead mall video it does show a bunch of
older interiors and [ __ ]
you know it means some retro uh uh
early 1900s maybe like 1920s 1930s
deserted towns you know it has some
pretty cool shots of that it did kind of
take me back
and the clothes and uh you know
um had oh what's her name when she was a
baby linda hamilton
linda hamilton as a baby yeah she wasn't
quite a baby this came out the same
year's terminator although i think she
might have shot
it because i think terminator came out
later she looked a little bit younger so
i'm assuming that i mean she had better
hair in this for sure because that was
kind of like
yeah i i think i read the book but i
didn't
i don't recall being that impressed with
the
it's a real short story it's not even a
book but it's a short story really and i
must have read it because i read a lot
of his show it was in night shift
yeah i read that one so yeah i had night
shift yeah
i still have it yeah so i i did read it
i just didn't remember that much about
it
the movie it shot in a way that is very
familiar
to our generation it's very
um coherent there's nothing stylistic
about it or anything it's very point a
to point b
it's just a straightforward almost
generic
kind of production but that might be a
good thing you know what i mean it's
it's
it's tv movie like yeah which isn't
necessarily a bad thing because they
made a lot of
good tv movies and a lot of good tv like
stephen king adaptations like salem
salem's lot for example yeah but yeah
but you know there was nothing like
stylistically that like stuck out
about this movie it was very workmanlike
exactly
that's a good way of putting it yeah
which which you know
that kind of that kind of that kind of
holds up over time in a certain way
yeah because the movie is very coherent
and it's a very linear storytelling
well it's a very simple story they don't
really need to do anything fancy with it
even though they changed it a lot from
the short story because like i said the
short story i think was first published
in 1977 i want to say i think it
was in penthouse or something like that
because a lot of his early short stories
can turn up in skin mags
but then it was like you know
anthologized later when night shift came
out
and the story is like super super short
so obviously they had to add
a bunch of [ __ ] like to the movie and
i guess stephen king wrote the original
screenplay for this but the producer
did not like it was because he's the
producer said look
dude the first 35 pages of your
screenplay is just
your two protagonists the couple like
arguing with one another in the car
and it's like when and it's funny
because the producer i don't know
exactly what he said to stephen king but
he said
like stuff that i've said about stephen
king in the past it's like dude uh
film is a visual medium yeah um stuff
that works in a short story like
you know doesn't necessarily work in a
filmic
kind of uh you know context yeah so
um it's like yeah we don't we don't want
half an hour of like two people just
bickering at one another in the car
yeah so we need like some other way to
approach this
so they had to add a bunch of stuff from
the story because in the short story
which like i said is only a few pages
long
maybe four pages if i remember correctly
basically all that happened this is
spoiler alerts like for a 1977 short
story and a 1984 movie obviously so
don't get upset at me but
you know basically in the story uh the
couple who are named burton vicki
um they're going they're actually
driving across country to go to marriage
counseling or something like that i
don't know why they couldn't find
marriage counseling where they lived
whatever so and they basically can't
stand each other
so they're just like arguing and arguing
the whole time but um they you know they
hit a kid
they end up having to go to this little
bitty town called gatlin
and um basically all the kids there who
have got religion uh end up killing them
they they both die uh so which does not
happen in the movie
but the interesting thing too is that in
the short story
it's been a way longer time since the
kids killed the adults
i think it's been 12 years whereas in
the movie it was only four years at
three or four years
um so like in the story um
they're already on the second generation
because they're already having kids
like the little the teenagers are were
already having kids
yeah and it's kind of it's kind of like
logan's run with carousel you can't make
it to 19 to kill you they sacrifice you
yeah yeah that's that's essentially i
forgot that element
but yeah and that's like from the short
story too because and like i said in the
short story since it's been such a long
time
um the characters of isaac and malachi
are mentioned
but i don't even think isaac was born
like when because i think he was a
second generation person in the story
so he wasn't even born like because in
the movie he's kind of like the
mastermind behind the
massacre of the adults but he wasn't
even born in the story
and he's not really like a big character
in the story either
i thought they did a good job though of
representing this individual medium i
mean they show the little [ __ ] temple
little churches with the [ __ ] evil
[ __ ] jesus the corn jesus and that
that corn jesus is pretty creepy
holy the so-called unholy [ __ ]
paintings of [ __ ] gorillas coming out
[ __ ] people kids would do you know
i liked that i mean like you said
earlier you
if a movie is dialogue based i check out
i think it's a failure of cinema to have
that
[ __ ] a movie is actually just
glorified comic book strip
and what's the movies i tended to like
started out as a big old storyboard and
that's really you know because it's a
visual medium
uh like a good example all right codan
conan books
they tried to do a real accurate this is
recently i saw a review on it they tried
to do a real
accurate illustrated
version of a conan novel it failed
because
it's mostly talking and that's makes a
really [ __ ] boring comic book
marvel's version of that of it the comic
book version of it from the 70s and the
80s was exciting it was nothing but
conan running around fighting monsters
and chopping people's heads off
and that was very successful comic book
it's a different medium
if for me film and cinema
it's like a comic strip it's got you got
to show a lot of [ __ ]
and this movie kind of this movie did
that it did that it keeps you in the
story and
and every there was always constantly
something happening
it had suspense although it did seem to
take
it did seem like they were driving
around for a long time before they
actually
yeah i'm like how many days has passed
they're still driving
they're still driving around they still
can't get into the town it seems like a
couple days have passed
well one thing that i had forgotten
about like because i've cause like i
said i saw this movie a million times
when i was a teenager but i hadn't seen
it for probably like at least 20 years
one aspect that i had forgotten about
was that in the movie and this is not
from this
this uh is is a film original in the
movie
it almost seemed like the you know he
who walks behind the rose
was like making it so that that so that
they couldn't
get out of the town yeah but i don't
know if that was like supernatural or if
it was because because they made a
couple comments like that the signs were
like pointing different ways like gatlin
this way gatlin this way like a mile
later
so i don't know if the kids rearrange
them to keep people away or
people in there there's like some [ __ ]
in here that doesn't really make a whole
bunch of sense well there has to be some
explanation of how the kids could be
um be in there on their own for for such
a for such a long time without anybody
checking in on them yeah wondering what
happened to the to
their relatives and stuff so their head
and then
just regular strangers showing up and
delivery people and maintenance people
yeah people bringing fuel and people
fixing power lines you know
eventually they would find out someone
would notice
that there was no even in a pre-internet
era yeah they would find out that the
town didn't have any adults in it so
there had to be some kind of an ex
i think it was a mixture of both i think
it was their supernatural forces
demonic forces were keeping people out
and
and also the kids were [ __ ] ordered
to do [ __ ] like rearrange signs and
stuff by the this demonic
being because i feel like nobody like
nobody had come
through there in like all this you but i
i kind of
maybe i'm like overthinking this baby
this is my like my writer brain
i'm kind of justifying it by saying well
he who walks behind the rose every now
and then they need like another
sacrifice like an extra sacrifice of
some quote unquote outlanders
so at that stage he'll kind of like
rearrange [ __ ] to make it so that a car
will come by
and get lost and they won't be able to
get to the next town
uh which i think was hemmingford yeah
but even back in those days missing
people [ __ ] they would have tracked
it down where they went missing
yeah but it's a movie they had a psychic
girl that could tell them when people
were coming
yeah so maybe the the demonic force that
was running the show
also knew who they could kill and no
questions would be asked
yeah i mean like you know but i you're
reading into it too much well that's
what i'm saying but that's what i that's
what i do
yeah the thinking of the time thinking
of the time is that it was just a
[ __ ] movie and they're telling you to
tell you weren't supposed to read too
much into it and then you're dealing
with stephen king and that [ __ ]
was all so much coke and drinking so
much he just
especially in the 80s he was just
pulling [ __ ] out of his ass you know it
was they were good stories though
i actually i actually liked this story
and um i think when i first saw the
movie
i think i saw the movie before i read
the story and then when i read the story
i was like really surprised because it's
really different
like i said the whole dynamic between
bert and vicki in the short story
is completely different like they can
they're already married they've been
married a long time and they completely
loathe each other
and in the movie they're like i i don't
think they're married yet
and they're like real lovey-dovey i mean
i guess they had to do that to make it
so like it would be more
um you know emotionally affecting when
she gets kidnapped by the killer kids
and then gets put up on the [ __ ] you
know corn crucifix or whatever across
from the blue man
um in the story uh vicki gets killed
and like she gets crucified and then
they like tear her eyeballs out and like
put [ __ ] corn husks in the eyeballs
and everything
and he be i think he sees it and he's
basically like meh
but then he gets killed too right so by
he who walks behind the rose
so basically the story if you haven't
seen it and the weird thing about it is
that children of the corn even though
it's not
i mean it's an okay movie it's not a
fantastic movie but it's funny how
ingrained it's become in
pop culture like even nowadays because i
mean if you say well like i've
seen [ __ ] on like south park i've seen
[ __ ] about like where people be like
outlander and like everybody knows about
like [ __ ] isaac and malachi and all
that kind of [ __ ]
and you know if you say children to the
corn people know exactly what you mean
it's just like all these little rube
children like living out the middle of
nebraska or wherever
and it's like you know you you go
through the town and they [ __ ]
kill all the adults so everybody knows
about that and did you know i did not
know until today
i knew there had been a sequel which i
think was called the final sacrifice
um which i think i might have seen
because i read the wikipedia thing and
i'm like that sounds
vaguely familiar so i might have seen
that on cable at some point do you know
there are
10 of these [ __ ] movies 10 of them
yeah
and actually terrible i never hear them
well they're not like
there's not like any narrative
continuity it's kind of like a thing
where
they just kind of take the premise of
like the killer kids like out in the
middle of it
and then they kind of like have you know
kind of stand-alone stories
about people that lived in the town or
once lived in the town and left and then
came back
and they have [ __ ] like that and also
sci-fi channel did a remake of it in
2009 which i had no idea about which
i heard was a little bit closer to the
story and it was like passable it was
fine
and i heard that they were doing another
remake of it like that's supposed to be
coming out next year
but i don't you know i don't know how
that's gonna go but like i said
um this is basically the story is
there's this little town
four years ago all the kids like got
religion isaac was the main guy
played by john franklin who he um
he's great in this but the thing about
it is that
he's supposed to be a kid and he kind of
looks like a kid
but when he shot this i think he was 25
but he had some kind of
um he had some kind of growth hormone
like an illness that made him
childlike um so i think that was one of
the
reasons they wanted him in the movie
because there's something kind of like
unsettling about him i guess because
he's like an adult but he's like a kid
at the same time
but that's why because he had that kind
of like a malady
he also turned up in one of the sequels
maybe the fifth or the sixth one which i
think was isaac's return or isaac's
revenge or something like that
but he wasn't in some of the other ones
and i think he actually like maybe had
written the um
the screenplay for that or co-written
screenplay but um so basically he's like
the the mastermind malachi
is kind of like his muscle i guess it's
like he's his second in command the one
that goes out and does all the dirty
work
whereas isaac is kind of the one that's
like you know he who walks behind the
rose and he talks to me and he tells me
what to do and [ __ ]
so they've basically got this weird
pagan corn-based
religion which um is some kind of demon
apparently telling them
it's it's a folk religion like a harvest
kind of we need
like to you know put blood in the earth
and then it makes the corn grow
and that's what they use everything for
like they use the corn for everything so
it's kind of like this weird kind of
pagan kind of [ __ ] that they're doing
but the thing about it though
is like you can tell that the movie and
the short story to an extent also
they're kind of talking about like you
know the dangers of like fundamentalist
religion and everything like that but
you kind of
undermine your message a little bit
because he who walks behind the rose in
the movie is real
i mean you see him at the end he it
looks terrible
it's a terrible special effect um even
for the time
but he's but it but it's like so it's
kind of hard to be like hey you kids are
so dumb it's like with
this dumb religion but about well the
demon's real though i mean it's
working but i also detected what it was
is that you're kind of dumb if you
listen to [ __ ] mysterious demonic
forces out to death that's true
yeah you could you're dumb if you listen
to some [ __ ] like that
because remember uh some [ __ ] had
happened in the movie
before they got there the the the the mr
kappas man what did he call him
uh oscifer ossifer what's his name yeah
the kids called him awesome yeah the cop
figured out what the hell was going on
and was trying to use a religious right
out of the bible to
destroy the demon but he got killed he
got killed before yeah he was able to
complete it
so some people had tried to prevent it
beforehand or or on to it
so these people showing up in the town
weren't the first ones that tried to
combat this thing which i kind of liked
that element
yeah because there was a hero before who
had fallen yeah i don't know anything
about it
he was the cop yeah the cop tried to
stop it
and then and then they like they ended
up crucifying him and sacrificing him
because he's still there because when
vicky gets crucified he gets like but
the thing about it is that they call him
even though job one of the main kid
characters who was
was not in the story they added uh job
and sarah those two kid characters
just so you could have a perspective on
the town like before
burt and vicky got there you know what i
mean so they wanted somebody that
already lived there that was like
rebelling against the [ __ ]
so they could have somebody to work
together with the protagonists so it's
like
the it's it's weird that he knew the
officer's name
i can't remember what the officer's name
was officer hawkins or something like
that yeah
but um it made more sense in the story
because they in the movie they called
him the blue man
but it made more sense in this in the
story for them to call him the blue man
because
they wouldn't have known that that was a
cop because some of them were so young
that they didn't remember like who that
was or what that uniform was
you know what i mean because they'd just
grown up there so the fact that like
so i think that was kind of a plot hole
that they maybe should have carried over
but maybe
maybe in the movie they thought well 12
years
like that's a really long time and like
for nobody to notice that like these
kids are running around
a muck stephen king if you read all his
works he's not
anti he's not anti-religious or
anti-supernatural supernatural [ __ ]
happens all the time in his books and
it's real
what he what he was talking about in the
story and then when he talks about
a lot of stories is that you shouldn't
listen to [ __ ]
demonic and false type gods they're real
but they're bad yeah and that and so the
movie kind of holds true
to kind of like the entirety of i don't
remember the short story that
that well i remember just to cut just i
remember that i read it
yeah i don't remember many details about
it um
but it goes along a stephen king type
theme which is in a way a lot like
lovecraft
because he was yeah lovecraft would say
the same thing like oh yeah
you're dumb for following an evil god
yeah evil gods exist
yeah [ __ ] you over because remember the
the hero the story the protagonist he
said
he he he was like you guys should know
better you killed your own parents and
you're following this evil thing you
know
yeah so you know so that that that
message is put out there
yeah he's not because i feel like
stephen he's saying that this is a false
religion he said this is a real religion
he does
actually like a lot of his short stories
do kind of like take pokes at like
fundamentalist religion for real but i
do think that he
i i mean from everything i know he is a
christian so he's not like
so much [ __ ] on religion
fundamentally i remember the protagonist
basically said
he said he said you shouldn't be
following false religions that real
religion has compassion and
you know yeah any any religion without
love and compassion it's not a real
religion it's not right but he wasn't
saying that the demon wasn't real
yeah the demon had given them a false
religion that's that was
and that that kind of lines up more of
the thinking of the time and then
the thinking of stephen king you know
when you read a lot of his books
i always wonder if because he's he's
real in this story as well
because they do kind of show him i don't
think he describes him like super
you know uh i don't remember him
describing him like really uh
in detail or anything other than having
like really big red eyes and [ __ ]
in this they kind of make him look like
a mushroom cloudy type thing
just like a cloud and like i said this
the the special effects in this are just
so so bad which is kind of a shame but
now i'm kind of like interested to know
if the story would have been more
interesting if you didn't know
if the demon was real or not or if these
kids were just
not a bit it's more interesting to know
that it was real to know that it was
real
i think so yeah that it was it was a
real monster and it was really doing
[ __ ]
yeah because i mean basically like it at
the end of the movie
because like i said this movie ends this
movie actually has a happy ending
um unlike the story which has a terribly
horribly bleak ending
but you know in the movie both of them
live
and the two kids who are not even in the
story they
are basically implying that they're
going to adopt these two kids
like they're like yeah we're going to be
one big happy family we're going to take
you out of this like [ __ ] town or
whatever yeah it was the time you had to
have a happening heading into the time
yeah because i feel like the story like
i said they both died
she got killed the vicky got killed um
he was just like mad good riddance
but then he got killed too but he who
walks behind the rose killed bert
and at the end of the story um
he who walks behind the rose was pissed
because he had to like
get off his like fat demon ass and kill
bert himself instead of the kids doing
it because they whiffed it
so he basically he who walks behind the
rose told um whoever
i think amos or whoever the [ __ ]
prophet was in the story
that it's like okay well now we i used
to sacrifice all you [ __ ]
at 19. now it's 18. you know what i mean
now the only rebel in the story and she
appears in the movie too but not in a
huge role
was the pregnant girl yeah um she was
actually
she didn't do anything in the story but
at the end of the story she was pregnant
and she was looking out saying you know
maybe i should burn this [ __ ]
cornfield down
as i was watching it again and they and
they showed the inside of the church and
the way they had it all arranged
it well my stomachs grow i never get
hungry
as i was as i was watching it i was like
man this is basic this is a lovecraftian
message
this is basically very similar to like
the cult of dagon
yeah yeah dagon was a was was not a he
was a real god he was a sea god
he's evil this is the corn god he was a
real god yeah it's the same kind of
thing they had a cult
and they were doing the same they were
sacrificing it was a
lovecraftian type of mess and that that
goes in line with you know
with with king king read he knew
everything he yeah he was a big lover
yeah and that was the angle he
approached religion
you know if you if you look at like the
entirety of what at least of what i
remember stephen king's work like the
talisman
and you know and the shining
king believed that if you believed in
the religion and it was a good religion
then it would work
like your faith in it would say like
protect you against a vampire yeah
it didn't have to be christianity it
just had to be as long as you believed
that
you believed in it and you and it was
good yeah and you could and you had the
faith in it then it would work
and that's that's which is really the
only kind of religion i can get behind
yeah well yeah and in the story you may
be saying the fundamentalism in any
religion
including these cults is all dangerous
yeah it's bad right
it's more about an inner your inner
connection with the universal god
that's that's what and just be cool
about compassion and doing the right
thing
and you know not doing useless [ __ ] like
human sacrifice you know that's that's
what he
that's what king believed in basically
yeah yeah which like i said that's
totally a message i can get behind
but yeah like i said so so this movie
as i said it's obviously not up there
with dead zone or the shining or misery
or like any of the
or even like green mile or anything like
that this i would put
in mid-tier like stephen king
adaptations not
like i said not as terrible as some of
the other ones that they
made yeah it's not the first one you go
to but like after you've seen the good
ones you move on to this one it's just
more
of it and it's not as artistic
yeah they did do a good job inside like
the special effects for
say like the the church and certainly
you know it was kind of creepy with the
crucifixion
yeah the acting it was effective but
like you said earlier it was workmen
like
yeah and i will say the acting in this
is a little
uneven um it's acting of the time even
linda hamilton was a little
um not bad but just like not i didn't
really get a sense of her character
she didn't really have a lot to work
with um i do
feel like the relationship with her and
bert was okay um bert was pissing me off
because
so they hit the kid with the car you
know the kid that's trying to escape
and that's also what happened in the
story like he gets his throat cut they
throw him in the road and then they hit
the kid and bert is just [ __ ] bound
and determined to like find some
place to go to like report the death and
everything which
okay good but the if i drive into a town
in the middle of [ __ ] nebraska and
there's nobody around like no cars or
anything like that and then i just see a
bunch of kids trying to steal my car i'm
getting the [ __ ] out of that
i'm not hanging around looking for
another house so it's like linda
hamilton's character vicky is just like
can we leave now please and i'm just
like please
listen to her and he's just like oh it's
a little weird around here but nothing
to be alarmed about like five minutes
before she gets kidnapped
he didn't have much street wisdom
because i was like
this is more than a little weird dude
around his car and [ __ ] he was like well
just weird [ __ ]
yeah this show is some weird [ __ ] they
do i'm like no that's a little more like
weird
out of here yeah it's like let's
walk to the next town if i had to [ __ ]
this [ __ ] like i said he didn't see any
horror movies
but so i can get that like i will say
the interesting thing about the two
little kids who played job and sarah who
like i said were not
they did had no equivalents in the uh in
the story really they were just there as
kind of like
the audience you know go-to like into
the town so you could see what was going
on in the town before the main
protagonist got there
i think that might have been an attempt
by the director
to um kind of what's the word
not to totally cast aspersions on every
child in the town that
some children were good i think that's
what that attempt was yeah because those
two kids were like wise to from the
beginning they were just like [ __ ] this
i don't know i don't want to be a
condemnation of
children i think yeah they they don't
want to make it so like all the time all
children
will [ __ ] kill your kids they can't
kill their parents and stuff i think
that
but you know in a book that's more
effective yeah it's more effective that
no
it got them all they got all the kids
yeah well like i said even in the story
like there was a
one kid particularly that one girl that
was pregnant but she was like young she
was like
yeah you don't want to piss off the
parents though and and the people that
have children in the audience
yeah because they're like my kid
wouldn't do that my kid would be like
these good kids they had a boy and a
girl in there say dennis
yeah that's what that's one of each yeah
the other ones they were bad kids
so i i know the thinking of the time
yeah they're trying to sell the movie
they're trying to make the movie yeah
appeal to a widest
audience possible and that's how you do
it that's how you that's how you get out
of that
conundrum yeah yeah but yeah so like i
said so it was kind of a win-win but i
will say that it's inter i'm not sure if
they shot this in sequence
but it seems like the two kids their
acting was kind of
they were real annoying at the beginning
i have to say like especially the one
scene where
they were talking to the um the one kid
what the hell was the one kid that
escaped or was trying to escape like
through the cornfield and then got hit
by burton vicki's car
um which was actually like a really i
had forgotten how graphic that
scene was like with that kid getting hit
with the car was just like wow that
looks really
real um yeah it was a little upsetting
but um so
the scene with them like when they're
talking to him and he's like yeah i'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here and i'm
he's got his little suitcase or whatever
because i think he's gonna turn 18 or 19
soon and he doesn't want to sacrifice
himself like you're supposed to
so um i did like danny in the shining
then but um
so so then go so that scene is like
seemed very awkward to me because
i i think the thing about it is that
the thing about the tone of this
particularly in the beginning i think
the kids acting got better like as the
time went on
you know what i'm saying like as the
movie went on so that's why i'm saying i
don't know if they shot in sequence or
not because the kid got
that especially the boy like got better
at then that kid was in [ __ ]
monster squad too i think like later on
but um
but so it was kind of it was almost kind
of like the tone of it
was almost like those kids i'm not gonna
say they thought they were in a comedy
but it's almost like the tone of
of their performance like could have
turned into a comedy at any moment
do you get what i'm saying me towards
the end well toward the beginning
towards the beginning
and they seemed a little at the end
there was comedy i mean the kid was
trying to help and then
but i liked that get out of here and
he's like well
excuse me excuse me for helping your
stupid ass
yeah i think that was i think that was
another uh
thing that the director wanted to do he
wanted to show that the good kids
actually were kind of
being heroic and helping to fight the
demon
yeah that's because they made they had
to live in the [ __ ] they saw like all
the people get killed
for a movie for a mainstream movie where
you're trying to make money at the box
office
i kind of agree with that with that
decision that yeah i liked them more
i liked the kids more toward the end
when they were like you know heroin up
you know and then you're kind of going
taking it back to
the success of poltergeist because the
kids were
helping out to fight yeah poultry guys
did you know they get
to get the little girl back and stuff
you know so that i think they tried to
go that way which
yeah that's how i would i liked that but
yeah so like i said what what i was
talking about not so much the end
because like i said i thought they
got better toward the end but almost at
the beginning i think something that
bugs me
like it didn't bug me back then but i
think it bugs me now is i didn't like
the kids narration at the beginning you
know what i'm saying
i don't think that they needed that i
mean i think that you could kind of see
what was going on
and you didn't really need i mean maybe
they were afraid that the audience
wasn't going to be on board with it and
they were just kind of like well we need
this kid like narrating like what
happened
but i don't think it needed it probably
not now you know what i'm saying like
narration
that's things that could be fixed to
edit yeah so i could have done without
that but like other than that okay
we know there's different cuts of this
movie not that i ever heard but i mean
this is the only cut i've ever seen
um it needs it needs a digital remaster
if you ask me
yes it doesn't look that all that it
looks a little bit
faded and old yeah yeah it doesn't look
like it's gotten like the
treatment well at least the version we
watched we watched the version
which is on uh 2b and so i don't know if
that's like the most recent like upgrade
or whatever
but i do feel like i mean this is like a
apparently a popular franchise because
like i said they made 10 of these
[ __ ] movies plus like two remakes uh
you know one in 2009 and one that
they're
apparently working on or is slated for
next year
um i will say to you the guy that plays
uh that played malachi
courtney gaines he like wildly overacts
in this but i think that
that is one of the most appealing things
about the movie like him and isaac
are just like so over the top that i
think that's why
if they hadn't been like that i think
maybe this movie would have been like
forgotten
also shout out because courtney gaines
that actor was also in
the burbs yeah like he played like one
of the weird like clopic
family or whatever we reviewed that one
about a while back too i detected for me
that the the tone of the movie they were
trying to give you as much
bang for your buck as possible with a
pretty limited budget and it kind of
there's there's not very many sp not
much special effects in the movie
yeah so they're just trying to make the
movie stand out they're trying to make
the movie exciting and scary
just but with the actors alone so i i
think probably i'd agree with the
the director's direction with that yeah
to do that
like you said the movie would have been
forgotten without it yeah i do feel like
it needed some of that
it needed some pop so that's how they're
gonna make it pop i mean like
pop with the actors yeah and i mean like
i said isaac i think is the best thing
about it
it is on the top but hey it's the tone
of the movie
and it the movie's been remembered
that's true like i said it really like
seeped into the public
even people that i don't even even
people that haven't seen
the movie or sat through the movie if
you say children of the corn everybody
knows exactly what you mean
which that's something i recommend the
movie if you've never seen it it's a
very
easy watch it's not demanding on you
it doesn't have some kind of [ __ ]
sophisticated edit or it's not real
artistic
you can just watch the movie it's very
easy to follow
it is entertaining uh you wonder what
the hell's gonna happen next
you don't really get bored with it so
for the amount of money they spent on
the movie
yeah they did a good job they did yeah i
said i don't even think
i don't even think they spend a million
on this if i'm remembering correctly i
can't even remember
but like it's incredible i mean the gore
effects particularly the the practical
effects like the kid getting hit by the
car and [ __ ] like that that looks really
good yeah the only
effects that are not good or the one
like he walks behind the roads at the
end it's like really really bad like
early yeah
explosions and it's like cartoonish
stuff but hey you know what that was
just the way it was in those days
and i think that that the cheesiness
like adds to its appeal
yeah you know what i mean so i can see
why it's been remembered kind of fondly
it took over the years it's a movie and
it's doing what movies did back then
it's not trying to [ __ ] it's not
trying to show you it's not trying to
fool you into into like
a feeling where you're observing reality
it's not like that it's like
it's a theatrical production in form of
cinema cinema cinema what's that you
you say that's like uh it sure was a
movie or what was that quote that you
had that i said that i just said
that i just put on the [ __ ] front of
every blue ray cover
it is it's a movie
[Laughter]
well let's do between flicks and movies
and you know
cinema and you know [ __ ]
you know also some of it's just [ __ ]
yeah it's not [ __ ] it's good
yeah and it's it's a fun watch if you're
into like 80s movies if you're into and
like i said it's kind of in the middle
of the stephen king adaptations
not as not as good as some of the ones i
like well you know not even as good as
christine which i actually think is
really
the greatest fire starter which i like
fire started i like fire starters well
we need to review that one of these
we haven't done fire starter fire
starter the dead zone
we did dead zone we did christine
shining
i liked i liked that made for tv showing
a lot of people didn't like it i liked
it
i didn't like it uh well that's all
that's on you
i gotta go man i i'm [ __ ] starving
all right so uh yeah children of the
corn from 1984
it's actually on 2b right now for free
if you want to watch it i think one of
the
uh later uh sequels children of the corn
genesis or something like which is like
the [ __ ] eighth or ninth one or
whatever
i think that's on there as well i
haven't watched it i'm sure it's
probably not that good but if you're
really into it you can like watch it if
i was gonna watch it today but then i
was just like nah never mind i got
better things probably be disappointed
better things to do but yeah so you can
check it out by all means
uh and that'll do it for this review of
children of the corn we will see you
next time
bye